This picture that we have here actually
puts a number of different concepts,
in terms of how they're
related to each other, so
let's just sort of quickly
look at it from two sides.
People who rely on computer systems and
network systems, these are owners
of the data that's stored, and
the systems where the data is stored.
They deploy those because those
are critical towards the do.
At the same time we know that
there are threat sources and
they're going to pose threats to
the systems that we're talking about.
But one way we deal with
both the threat source and
a vulnerability that we may
have is deploying defenses.
Owners obviously want
to reduce this risk.
And one way to do that is to deploy
the defenses that we have in place.
And the risk is to the online assets
which are valued by the owners.
That's sort of the picture
on the legitimate owners and
what they do in cyberspace.
In terms of the attackers, or
the malicious actors, threat sources,
they basically increase risk to
these online assets that we have.
And that happens because they exploit
vulnerabilities and launch attacks.
By doing that they wish to profit and
that's the way they do it.
The big picture is sort of the center is
what is of value, who poses a threat and
what do we do to somehow manage
the risk that we have for
our online assets from
the threat sources.
But the key concepts in cyber security,
this diagram sort of nicely relates
the idea of threats, vulnerabilities,
attacks, cyber risk, and so on,
and how they're all connected.